en 2021 les extraterrestres viennent
d'arriver sur terre pour en parler
jean claude bourret
bonjour bonsoir bonsoir est ce que tu as
fait un bon voyage à travers l'espace
font d'abord oui je me suis désintégrer
réintégrer c'est un petit peu éprouvant
mais au bout de quelques bleus tout va
bien la preuve tu faisais quoi quand je
t'ai demandé de te téléporté dans cette
émission est bien j'étais
sur une antenne de télévision qui
s'appelle la sec en 2021
en 2004 il n'a pas tellement changé
finalement cette fait quel âge il a 81
ans exactement
la santé ça va la santé ça va oui on a
des moyens pour la conserver ouais
à l'époque tu t'occupais avec d'autres
d'ailleurs d'une chaîne qui s'appelait
la chaîne pour l'emploi et qu'il devait
durer trois semaines ça s'est passé
comment elle a vraiment duré trois
semaines
pas plus pas plus on sera au bout de
trois semaines y avait plus de chômeurs
en france
non il y avait plus de budget à dakar
alors comment tu expliques qu'à l'époque
avec 77 % des téléspectateurs qui qui
qui voulait être voir à la télévision
n'avait pas d'ennemis
ah non non non ça c'est jean claude
bourret sais pas mais médéa non plus et
panis ppd animé médias oui bon c'est pas
ppda furieux alors comment tu expliques
qu'à l'époque avec 77% des gens qui vont
être voir télévision tu n'avais pas
d'émission ben on pourrait dire que vox
populi vox nenni puisque on n'a pas tenu
compte effectivement dorée demande des
téléspectateurs mais le plus important
dans la vie c'est de trouver un sens à
sa vie et pas forcément de correspondre
à ce que souhaitent les sondages
à l'époque en 94 j'avais écrit déjà cinq
ou six bouquin sol et sur les ovni sur
les extraterrestres
c'étaient les prix comme on ce truc là
que comment t'es venue cette passion
pour sa hausse est très ancien c'était
en 1973 le 30 novembre 73 très
exactement allié à 18h30 et très précis
c'était à turin en italie où deux avions
qui était en approche de l'aéroport ont
vu un objet volant non identifié cet
ovni a été détectée par deux radars un
photographe professionnel a pris des
photos et tout cela était racontée par
la fp l' agence france-presse
j'ai donc décidé de vérifier cette
information qui me paraissait
complètement farfelu
c'était vrai voilà comment tout a
commencé tu passais un peu en 94 faut le
dire pour un doux dingue avec tes
histoires de venir non oui oui dès que
j'ai commencé à m'intéresser aux objets
volants non identifiés j'ai eu affaire à
quelques sourire sarcastique mais la
vérité a fini par voir le jour
qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis c'est à
dire entre 94 et 2021 ce qui a eu
d'autres manifestations aussi étonnante
que trans en provence par exemple turin
1999 un atterrissage près de langogne en
lozère avec apparition d'humanoïdes et
puis 2007 sur l'île d'yeu
et toutes ces affaires tous ces cas
accumulé n'ont fait que conforter la
population mondiale dans l'idée que les
extraterrestres peut-être nos visites et
donc finalement tu avais de moins en
moins tort d'une certaine façon il ya un
je n'avais ni tort des raisons c'est la
vérité oui et alors hier donc le 8 avril
2021 pour la première fois des
extraterrestres sont réellement apparu
et sont restés c'est quelque chose
d'exceptionnel c'est un peu comme neuf
pas depuis la pique l'homme avait marché
sur la lune on n'est pas vu un truc
aussi incroyable comment ça s'est passé
ça s'est passé ou d'abord ça s'est passé
à l'endroit tout à fait inimaginable
puisque ça a était sur le toit si j'ose
dire de l'arche de la défense peut être
que vu du ciel ça ressemble à un terrain
d'atterrissage pour objet volant non
identifié ils sont posés là haut est
l'engin s'étant posé ils sont sortis de
cet engin ils étaient cinq et ils sont
descendus avec des systèmes anti
gravitationnelle jusqu'au sol laissant
l'engin hors de portée du public
il ressemble à quoi il nous ressemble il
nous ressemble à nous ils nous
ressemblent c'est un petit peu plus
petits ils ont une tête assez grosse
c'est à dire qu'ils ont un cerveau plus
développé que le nôtre mais ils ont deux
yeux et une bouche comme vous comme nous
absolument c'est des petits airs 10 ans
et des petits bourgs et oui je sais pas
si c'est un progrès pour l'humanité mais
cela ils sont gentils c'est une vraie
graves questions a eu son gentil mais
dans les premiers contacts que nous
avons eus réellement avec eux ils nous
ont dit qu'il y avait d'autres
représentants extraterrestres qui
étaient extrêmement dangereux et
destructeur et les gens réagi comme on
quand c'est arrivé qui a été la première
réaction des gens bien oeil amusé un
mélange de d'entousiasme extraordinaire
et puis en même temps il n'y a pas eu
un choc émotionnel aussi grand qu'on
aurait pu l'imaginer parce que depuis
les années 1940 1950 il ya eu beaucoup
de films de science fiction
ouais sur le thème les extraterrestres
nous rendaient et ils viennent d'où ils
viennent d'une planète qui est située à
80 des lumières de la terre ils viennent
pour quoi faire au fait ils viennent
pour recevoir pour se voir oui vous avez
une bible bien sûr est ce que casino
dont on peut avoir une
une bible eyes ait toujours une voix
d'homme approche dans ma loge était
bourré merci beaucoup merci merci et
mais bien la 5
c'était il ya longtemps c'était hier
alors voyez vous thierry la vérité était
dans la bible depuis toujours les hommes
le sentais confusément il n'avait pas su
interpréter et tout est dans la bible
c'était écrit d'ailleurs ils ont des
yeux ne voient pas ils ont des oreilles
n'entendent pas écoutez bien ce passage
dieu a créé l'homme à son image de nous
avons dit dieu c'était les
extraterrestres qui ont fait un clonage
et qui nous ont injecté l'adn notre
programmation génétique l'acide
désoxyribonucléique et c'est écrit dans
la bible il est écrit en effet alors y
avait lieu fit tomber une torpeur sur
l'homme on voit l'anesthésié générale
l'homme est plongé dans un profond
sommeil et s'endort alors y avait dieu
pris une de ses côtes et referma la
chair à sa place c'est écrit dans la
bible on voit bien l'opération
non seulement les extraterrestres ont
créé l'homme à leur image donc nous
entrés et nous sommes à leur image mais
la femme a été créé à partir d'une
manipulation génétique qui était fait
sur l'homme qui a été créée puis son
premier du clonage quoi c'est du clown
cirque en fait à l'époque on comprenait
pas bien
jusqu'au la fin du xxème siècle on
comprenait qu'on pouvait pas le
comprendre certains que le clonage
n'avait pas été réellement réalisé par
les scientifiques
on pouvait pas le comprendre mais cela
ne fait que reculer la question qui est
dieu et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux